just a heads up this video will contain
some spoilers for the Hyperion cantos in
this video I will go over the
significant confirm dates from the four
Hyperion Books this video will also
include dates from before the start of
the Empire known as the hegemony of man
more than two thousand years before in
fact
in the final book of the Hyperion cantos
rise of Endymion it was claimed by Ania
that Jesus of Nazareth was the first
human being to truly understand the void
which binds Christ had stayed long
enough within the void that he had
ascended to what Ania referred to as the
second level he could speak the language
of the Dead while dying on the cross
Jesus was able to move through space
time appearing to his disciples in the
future and liberated from the
restrictions of his time by his glimpse
of the timelessness of the void which
binds Jesus realized that it was he who
was the key not his teachings not
scriptures based on his ideas not
groveling Angelyn to him or the suddenly
evolving Old Testament God in which he
solidly believed but him Jesus a human
man who sells carried the decryption
code to unlock the portal jesus knew
that his ability to open that door lay
not in his mind or soul but in his skin
and bones and cells literally in his DNA
these events as described by Ania in the
final book in the series rise of
Endymion would have occurred around the
Year 33c II the EPOXI II denoting the
Common Era the next notable date within
the Hyperion cantos will be twenty
thirty eight C II when old Palestine
which had become its own nation for a
short time was destroyed by nuclear
jihad the year 21:43 C II is said to
mark the founding of the hegemony of man
this is also the Year Zero PC or present
calendar which can be used for days
following the founding though this year
is marked as the beginning of the
hegemony it wasn't until nearly a
century later that the fate of Old Earth
would be sealed in the year twenty to
thirty eight C II the event known as the
big mistake occurred in which an
experiment performed by a team of
physicists was said to have gone wrong
this created a black hole which would
devour the earth from the inside out
over the course of the next 100
sometime after the event occurred the
owl stirs left the planet Earth it is
not until the year 20 to 80 to seee that
the Hegira starts humankind fled the
planet in the mass diaspora into the
stars it would be several more decades
before the planet itself would succumb
to the black hole at its center and
there were still those who refused to
leave martin salinas one of the main
characters of the series and the only
one who lived on earth was born on the
planet in the year 23:18 seee
salinas left his home planet in the year
23:38 as it was consumed from within the
death of Earth the creature called the
Shrike first appeared on the outback
world of Hyperion in the year 25 33
it killed sad King billy friend of
martin salinas in the year 25 54 c ii
inside the city of poets in the year 27
32 Catholic priest Father de ray who
would eventually become infected by the
parasite known as the cruciform would
become stranded on the planet Hyperion
70 years later Rachel Weintraub daughter
of Saul Weintraub visited the time tombs
on the planet Hyperion and contracted
Merlin's sickness a mysterious disease
which caused her to age backward every
24 hours losing another day of her life
in the year twenty seven sixty one the
anti-entropic field surrounding the time
tombs began to expand and the final
strike pilgrimage began the tree ship
egg drasil a spaceship created and used
by the brotherhood of Muir is used to
deliver seven pilgrims to the world of
Hyperion during his 11 years as consul
on that distant and enigmatic world
the mysterious Church of the Shrike had
allowed a dozen barges of offworld
pilgrims to depart for the windswept
Barrens around the time tombs north of
the mountains no one had returned the
pilgrims arrive on the planet Hyperion
and make their way to the valley of the
time tombs in the year 27 64 in the year
2856
world web without the far casters the
hegemony could not function the dates
following the fall of the hegemony can
be marked with the epoch AF or after the
fall Raul and Demian the main character
of the final two novels was born in the
year 247 af the book in Demian opens in
the year 274 after the fall or 31:26 EE
after the fall of the hegemony packs
became the main government of the people
of the galaxy pax was under the control
of the Catholic Church who possessed a
large military divided into four groups
Swiss Guard Home Guard fleet and ground
force under the rule of Pope Julius the
church developed successful methods for
resurrection through use of a parasite
called the cruciform the pax era would
last 300 years before it would be
brought down the pax era would be
followed by the onion era though
specific dates are not mentioned from
the time Aniyah says jesus was said to
have traveled in the void which binds in
33 c ii to 274 after the fall when the
final book opens approximately 3,100
years passed
thank you guys so much for watching this
video if you enjoy the content make sure
you leave a like and subscribe I also
want to say that I'm happy that you guys
are liking the new science-fiction
content that I'm putting on this channel
I hope to continue to grow and diversify
my channel as time goes on right now I'm
gonna focus on dune Hyperion foundation
a Song of Ice and Fire
and then eventually I'm gonna start
moving into other science fiction books
and some other fantasy books including
but not limited to the culture series by
Ian banks which I have really enjoyed
reading it was another one that was
suggested by my subscribers and my
followers and I can't wait to start
sharing that series with everyone else
on the interwebs so if you really want
to support this channel and you really
appreciate the content consider clicking
the patreon link in the description and
consider donating a dollar or two a
month thank you guys so much for
watching peace out
[Music]
you